[Music]
you are listening to inside of you with
Michael rosenbom hi Ryan hi Michael
rosenbom this is uh one of those things
where it's late in the day Ryan took
Ryan forever to get here because traffic
his hair's a mess my hair is a mess both
of us didn't shower today showered last
night did not shower today well then I
was right so I correct yes I showered
yesterday as well I showered last night
so not together we weren't together no
we could try it though but yeah I have a
walk-in so we could there's plenty of
room you do and a bench if you want to
sit while I lather
up I got a I mean just to give you an
idea of my close living quarters I got a
text from uh my my building manager
lives next door to me and I got home uh
late last night cuz it was soccer night
and uh I got a text from my building
manager at 11:45 saying hey could you
not slam your toilet seat
down oh my God I would have said buddy
mind your own [__] mind your own [__] my
thought was okay she was having a day
like obviously this did you not slam
your toilet seat down I just heard it
for one second it was loud I I mean it's
just I put an egg in your shoe and beat
it anyway uh thank you for listening to
the podcast I know again you have a lot
of podcasts to listen to we've got a lot
of great podcasts coming up too I've got
some amazing guests um every week I
learn something and I know you will too
we talk about mental health we Deep dive
I have real conversations with folks
that you might not think are that real
because they're celebrities or whatnot
but uh I hope you're enjoying it if you
are enjoying it and you want to support
the podcast even more there's a thing
called patreon p a r o n patreon.com
inside of you and you could join and you
really help the podcast my patrons
without the patrons this podcast
wouldn't exist period just would not
exist couldn't do it so I want to thank
them all the patrons uh if you're top
tier patrons you get things like shout
outs in the beginning of the or
beginning end of the podcasts all your
name uh boxes sent from me with uh by me
for with little gifts and and notes and
uh you get to ask questions to guests
and it's just there's a lot of great
stuff on there so go to patreon.com
inside of you support the podcast today
um I'll try to send you a message and um
I will get around that and I thank you
you can also go to the inside of you
online store for great merch we're
talking uh Smallville script signed and
lunchboxes signed and tumblers from the
podcast and uh I look I have this little
jacket there's inside of you jacket
there's not many left though but um also
I'm having another live podcast that's
right uh I'm not going to announce it
this second I'm just telling you I'm
having one uh looks like it's going to
be late January so if in you're Los if
you're in Los Angeles it's going to be a
it's an amazing guest you are going to
love this woman she is fantastic
fantastic actress and we're going to
have a lot of fun at the live podcast so
you're going to have to get tickets once
I tell you when and who and all that
stuff but shouldn't I be enough Ryan
shouldn't they want to just come to the
podcast to see me probably not it's okay
it's all right I mean you know you think
that you think you are enough that's
what I always say no I don't I say be
good to yourself I don't say you're
enough it's part of it maybe that'll be
my new one it's in play he you're enough
it's in play that's you know what's
funny is that's that's story of being
you're enough like just be enough MH
you're good enough that's it you don't
have to be great just be just be good
enough you're good enough yeah anyway uh
we're gonna get into our Our Guest soon
um also you can go to my Instagram which
is at the Michael rosenbom and my link
tree shows any events coming up my band
sunspin playing sunspin do.com if you
want to support the band I think you'll
really dig the music we have two albums
out now working on a third and uh the
tville podcast tville podcast gu.com
tons emerge there's these new pieces of
art there are only 50 available prints
signed by me and Tom that you have to
get because we're running low now so if
you want to get those go to talk
podcast.com and thanks for all your
support and uh yeah the holidays are
close here Ryan they're very close MH um
I'm having Thanksgiving here you won't
be here you'll be with your family no I
will be no I'm coming here for
Thanksgiving oh you're coming here for
Thanksgiving right oh good yeah I'm
coming here specifically for
Thanksgiving I think that would be
really nice yeah I'm looking forward to
it it's always fun yeah I figured out I
could make stuffing Amanda wanted to
bring stuffing make stuffing and I I was
like what wet
bread I guess that's what it is it is
wet but no uh do they have gluten-free
stuffing uh this one will not be but but
I'll be all right it looked up a good
recipe and I we did a test run last
weekend and you did a test run did a
test run you guys are serious well
because I'm not I I wanted to I didn't
want to bring something in a tin I
wanted to be able to make it and I
wanted to try it out so I found a recipe
and went to
Pavilions got a lot of things and uh for
turned out well I like that it's going
to it's going to be good I have a
feeling it's going to be I wish other
people would test their product before
they bring
it some stuff isn't no most of the stuff
is really good I just Supply I don't S I
don't I don't have a signature dish yet
so I wanted to make sure this was
presentable I just Supply the house the
party the uh turkeys the mashed
potatoes things like that I think that's
a that's that's a turkeys are a big part
of Thanksgiving mhm so uh I'm good
enough uh David Crum Holtz is my guest
today you've seen him in so many things
the show Numbers you've seen him in um
the big movie Oppenheimer which he was
brilliant I I had to immediately text
him after and say wow wow uh he talks
about I believe his thyroid he talks
about his weight gain he talks about so
many things and gets personal and uh I I
I I love to hear what you think about
this our handles are at inside of you
podcast on Facebook and Instagram at
inside upod on Twitter you can watch us
on YouTube and listen to us everywhere
WR a review on Apple write a review
anywhere it really helps the podcast and
uh thanks for the support let's get
inside of David Crum hols it's my point
of view you're listening to inside of
you with my Michael Rosen
[Music]
B inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience you're is that what it
is your Killy seal I I I have the
strangest experience with Aaron Aaron
roders I did the Tribeca Film Festival a
few years ago and uh they asked me to be
a juror for like the best documentary
short category
and he was on my
jury and he didn't know why he was there
and I didn't know why he was there but
he was totally nice guy but you could
see in his eyes that he'd been
hit way too many times you could really
tell on you can really tell that it
looked like he had yes he was he look
he's he there was a crazed Maniac look
in his eyes really which I assume most
football players who've been dinged up
over time have
but I don't know how you don't get
injured immediately on every play the
way they hit each other and the the the
muscle and the speed and you know hockey
and all these Sports I don't know how
they do it and then you know they retire
and I have friends that have retired
that have you know had big injuries one
of my friends Pat LEF Fontaine he was a
star for the Islanders and you know
played for the Rangers but he had like
11 concussions and took him out in fact
he just designed this new helmet velour
he sent me one to help prevent
concussions but like when I talked to
him I I could see he's such a nice guy
such a sweet man and smart but you can
tell that he's been hit quite a few
times there's there's just a look in his
eye that's just a little bit like I have
been concussed so I understand what
you're saying yeah he definitely Aaron
Rogers definitely had that look and uh
do I have that look supposed to play
ever again after like one concussion
David do I have that look uh I can't
tell what the glasses on the glasses
make you look all right yeah there it is
that's it that's that's the look I'm
concussed you been concussed and it's
not a laughing matter we're not joking
about it but it's just I mean we are but
we're not um have you have you ever been
injured or had a real I mean I know look
I know we can get into it because we get
personal and and close here it helps a
lot of people but I mean I know you had
thyroid cancer I had the cancer yes I
mean is I you know when I hear the word
thyroid and cancer it just sounds like
that's not a good good cancer to
have you know it's not a bad cancer to
have uh Ian if you're cancer it's super
treatable um if you catch it on time the
problem is if you don't catch it if you
don't know you have it it can spread to
your lungs pretty quickly um I got crazy
lucky I got saved uh I I went to a
masseuse I went for a full relaxation
massage and at the end of the massage
she massaged my neck and I was like what
is she doing no one ever does that like
the front of my neck and at the end of
the massage my full relaxation massage
she told me she felt the lump and I was
like well that's not relaxing and then
I I didn't even think anything of it and
like three months later I went to the my
physical and my doctor was like you know
he checked me up and down and he was
like you know at the end of the session
he was like is there anything else you
want to tell me and I was like like you
know I went to this masseuse and she
told me I had a lump on my neck I don't
know and he felt my neck and he was like
there's two there's two lumps and I was
like oh [__] um he looked concerned he
looked he looked concerned well it was
concerning at the time as you can
imagine um but you know it was so it
came after I had had a nervous breakdown
that
year which all was because of the
thyroid like your thy stops functioning
and you get crazy depressed and like it
really messes with your head um so I it
kind of was like a relief I was like oh
that's why I've been freaking out is
like I've had I'm not healthy like I'm
not physically okay and um and it was
kind of like that year was so crazy that
just being told I had cancer was like
well of course I have cancer in fact I
went I went out to dinner with John
herwitz who created Cobra Kai and the
Harald and Kumar
movies and I told him I said you're not
going to believe this but I I have
cancer and he said of course you have
cancer I guess people just expect me to
be sickly but um that's terrible and
even just of course yeah yeah I thought
it was bad in the moment too I didn't I
didn't think it was funny but looking
back it was and uh and anyway I caught
it and it's super treatable and I'm
still in contact I found the
masseuse and I'm still in contact with
her I sent her a bunch of gifts she
saved my life and she didn't have to do
that and uh a little bit of an Angel
there and uh but like the the problem is
you lose your thyroid they removed my
whole thyroid right so I became super um
super fat is that what happens when you
lose your thyroid you get that I don't
know how these things work I'm severely
hypothyroid
and what that means is like I'm on the
highest dose of the medicine that people
take to replace their thyroid which is
called
Synthroid and
uh even with that dose man like I cannot
eat without gaining like tremendous
amounts of weight really fast like my
metabolism I would say like slowed down
by 100% or more like literally like my
it just uh and so i g i ballooned i
swelled up you know it was like I was
swollen it wasn't even fat it was like
SW good now I mean so how do you lose
weight if you have no thyroid you're on
these hypo you're on these drugs well no
one wants to admit this in Hollywood but
I'm gonna I'm gonna do it I'm gonna say
it right now I uh OIC is amazing really
dude OIC rules man so you're on OIC I
always joke I was like who is on OIC and
some people say I've been on Olympic for
about six months or seven months and uh
that's about it that's about all you're
supposed to take it for so I'm at the
end and I've lost 44 pounds feel good
easily um you know slowly which is good
you know like it's it's it's no more
than two pounds a week so I'm not like
losing a ton of weight I'm eating
smaller meals the only you know hard
part about OIC is the way it works works
is that it essentially makes you
nauseous but slightly nauseous but
enough where you're halfway through a
meal you get nauseous and you don't want
to eat anymore you know so you you you
know you're only eating half meals but
that's good you know you're you're
eating smaller meals that's what you're
supposed to do so it's good and and it
has some drawbacks but um it's worked
for me and does the nausea go away
quickly or is it just happen when you're
eating and then it it it sort of
dissipates or whatever after a while
depends on if you panic
um you know because it's such a gnarly
feeling um but no it doesn't last very
long it doesn't you know a couple burps
brings it up I just wait for the wait
for the for the burp yeah how much
weight what was the height of your
weight uh 23 does that make sense the
height of your weight the height of my
weight the weight of my height uh
232 at
5'6
My the average weight or the recommended
weight for a person that's 5 foot6 is
155 so 232 that was pretty overweight
right now being an actor and being in
Hollywood and look I think you're one of
the the best I think you're you're
tremendous I think you know I we can get
into that no but I just I really really
respect your work and even seeing
like highlights of uh Leopold schot is
that how you pronounce it yeah you know
that you put on Instagram I believe yeah
I put one I was I was I was blown away I
was like he's English
he's he's this character I haven't seen
you play something like that and you
know you got a drama League award get
nominated for a drama League award for
that and I'm like you know I always
thought you were a great actor but I was
like oh my gosh look at this he's on
Broadway he's a Broadway this is a
[__] actor thank you man
I inside of you is brought to you by
Aura frames I have one did you see it in
my living room yeah yeah you're in it
you're one of the pictures look th this
is pretty pretty badass the perfect
present guys doesn't always have to be
difficult to find a digital picture
frame from Aura frames is thoughtful
meaningful and perfect for pretty much
everyone they even come in a premium
gift box so shove that wrapping paper
back in the closet uh I it's so easy to
use use I pluged this in it's it's a
frame it's a digital frame it's
beautiful comes in this great box like
they said and I just added pictures
hooked it up to my internet and boom
downloaded tons of pictures and when
people walk into my living room they
don't just see one picture oh he's got a
picture of his other friend doesn't have
a picture of me I'm like I got a picture
all you in this digital frame from Aura
everybody's in this Frame if you just
sit there and watch it for the next five
minutes you're going to see yourself
it's uh it's pretty awesome uh who are
you most excited to give this picture
frame to huh I mean there's got to be
someone out there your mom your dad
filled with glorious pictures from your
your past or a 50th anniversary my my
parents were divorced in 27 years so
that never happened but you know what
I'm getting to uh pick one of their
frames easily set it up in minutes start
sharing your favorite photos and videos
using the free Aura app it comes with
unlimited storage and it's super secure
which is good to know you don't want
these personal pictures out or maybe you
do give the best gift ever this year you
have complete control over who has
access to your frame and the Aura app
lets you share photos more securely than
with email which many other digital
frames require Aura frames have
meticulously calibrated high resolution
displays unless you look really close or
see photo transition you never know it's
a screen that's for sure you look at it
you're like oh that's a cool P oh
there's another picture and another
uh react with cute emojis to show you
love of photo send congratulations and
much much more from now through Black
Friday and Cyber Monday visit Ora
frames.com and get $40 off their
bestselling Carver matte frame with the
code inside this is their best deal of
the year so get yours now that's Aura
a frames.com with the promo code inside
visit Ora frame fr.com for terms and
conditions today's sponsor nutrients.com
uses a CGM right here under my arm which
is a small device that provides
real-time feedback on how your body
responds to the foods that you're eating
your exercise stress and even your sleep
now this is something that look guys if
you see I'm wearing it I wearing my
glucose monitor because I have found out
I'm gonna get into this so just give me
a second uh nutrients
really monitors my glucose levels so
when I find myself crashing
tired you can just take your phone
because there's an app I put it under my
arm the sensor retrieves all the
information and it shows my glucose
levels for the last x amount of hours
and I go wow I spiked here well that's
cuz you had three root beers dude maybe
you shouldn't be having so much root
beer maybe you should keep your glucose
levels at a even place so you feel
healthier you feel better you feel have
more energy um you know it's not just
for people who are you know I guess
diabetic or whatever it's for people who
want to live a healthier life and that's
what's happened to me I didn't know what
this was and neutri sense changed my
mind on this whole uh outlook on on on
health um Nutri sense helps you analyze
your glucose levels in real time in
response to food exercise stress and
sleep new sense includes one month of
free board certified nutritionist
guidance and
support uh it really is awesome Ryan if
you want me to get you one um you could
your your life
it's it shows you what you're eating and
and and what you're doing you can
monitor all that you take notes on this
and it's just so easy to say okay I
remember I crashed her I was really
tired at 2:00 why well right here it
says well you spiked and you crashed and
this is why this happens and if you're
if you like if you work and you you
doing all these things you need more
energy you monitor your
glucose and it's just amazing my
nutritionist helped me interpret the
data and promptly answered all my
questions Patrick thank you Patrick over
at neutri sense I said well what are
these see how it spikes here and spikes
here well well what exactly are you
eating and drinking Michael and they you
know we managed it and I said what's
what are better things I could have in
my diet that I can get some energy but
won't crash and so he sent me a list of
things so it really is
wonderful in in just the short time that
I've done this I've noticed better sleep
I've noticed uh sustained energy less
brain fog it's because I'm not doing
eating all those bad things I'm not
having all that sugar and it's really
helped me and you know I'm 51 and I and
no matter how old you are you want to
have sustained energy throughout the day
and right now visit neutr sense.com
inside to save $30 and get one month of
free nutritionist support that's
nutrients.com
inside you know when you're 232 lbs I'm
sure people are kind of like on your
Instagram are looking go God this that
guy got that guy got fat yeah so I wish
I'd never been were you aware like were
you like were you embarrassed by it or
you were just like do you are
embarrassed by it yeah well I wish I'd
never been skinny you know or because
then people wouldn't do that but like
when I did like numbers for instance
like I was super skinny and then you
know you get big later in life for
whatever reason and you know and people
yeah people are mean about it um I don't
know embarrassed maybe I I was
disappointed Ed in myself and frustrated
because it wasn't like I was overeating
it was just I was gaining weight
regardless and that was really tough as
an actor like if I wasn't an actor I
guess I wouldn't care that much like
it's unhealthy but I wouldn't like have
Lo like tried to lose a lot of weight
you because you're not the Limelight as
much you're not like you know at all
when you're not an actor you don't have
to think about live in New Jersey [__]
it I'm Jersey skinny the 232 is is you
know Jersey athletic but
um uh yeah as an actor it started to
really bother me especially because it
just felt like oh no like I'm
not going to get I'm G to lose
opportunities and and then what happened
was you know I got a lot of like
opportunities to play chunky guys but
then there's always some like ribbing in
all these scripts you know like oh the
fat guy and you know and it was like wow
I guess that's that's what I've got to
do is is just be the big guy suddenly
and
um and I didn't like it yeah so so I've
made concerted efforts to lose weight
several times OIC is the first time that
I've done it in a healthy way I'll say
that why aren't they sponsoring you you
should be doing commercials for OIC I'm
ready would you do it if they were like
oh oh
zic you know
oh because I've heard like a lot of
actors in Hollywood are doing that but
you have an A an actual reason to Beyond
this you know there's like it totally
makes sense um yeah that's was it hard
for your personal life I mean was your
did you think your wife was unattracted
to you yes did she tell you yes
yes she did yeah well look she was like
she she made the mistake one day cuz I
was like I feel so big and I I don't I I
don't feel right and and she said so be
big who cares be big and I thought well
if she doesn't care then I'll just be
big but then I found out she did
care um and she's not a superficial
person she's not shallow but yeah you
know you feel I like you know you know
yeah when you're in Intimate situations
you're like suffocating a person you
know suddenly right the lights are off
potentially hurting someone you know um
I I keep the lights off anyway and I'm
not like like you know I keep the lights
on and I also keep my socks on do you
every time that's very Jewish of you it
is yeah you know keeping the sock you
don't keep your socks on do you uh I've
taken them off a couple times but I like
them on I don't know why does she like
them on I mean she take your socks off
um yeah I probably should I probably
should are they black socks they're
they're no they're they're white tube
socks white tube socks so you're nud
except for the white
Tu give me a nice little visual there I
can just see going to town in white tube
socks 232 pounds going to town with
nothing but white tube socks but you
know in a
way in a way this is
like you know dairo gains a whole bunch
of weight to play a character all these
actors do this you inadvertently gain
all this weight to to do this and you're
able to play characters that you
probably you wouldn't have played like
the character in the movie that in the
movie Oppenheimer you play this
physicist and he's he's a heavy
guy yes he the actual guy I played
wasn't as heavy as me but yes right so
but but I I was I thought you were
brilliant iant and I like that you
didn't look exactly like you used to
look that you looked more mature and you
look like this guy that could be this
guy it just it really just I was like
this you belong with all these great
actors like they belong with you so that
character yeah I mean would you have
wanted to play it
skinnier yeah you would have I don't
know man I me know I'm I'm vain I'm an
actor man I'm vain you know I'm not
going to lie um I am too you know you
know you worry it's just it comes with a
whole bunch of worry of then people go
oh well that's what he does you know
that's the thing is like they're always
trying to like audiences and the
industry alike want to know what they're
getting because they want to feel like
they're they know you you know and I
have
always with weight without weight with
my hair with whatever I've always tried
to switch it up because I don't find
myself that interesting at all because I
know I'm not I'm like kind of a boring
person and like um what you think you're
a boring
person you can't be a boring person
you're an actor I'm I'm not a boring
person I just don't find myself that
interesting I personally don't find
myself that interesting I'm probably a
very interesting person but I I'm not
interested anymore I lost many years ago
and for me it's like I just want to like
switch it up and and like surprise
people the surprise then you get away
with so much stuff when you can surprise
people I just thought I just thought of
a situation you know you're talking to
your girlfriend this is hypothetic
obviously cuz you're married and you're
like look this isn't going to work and
then she's like why well I've lost
interest she's like what do you mean in
myself I'm just not interested in myself
anymore I this isn't going to work I
have no interest in myself I don't find
myself interesting well I do yeah that's
tough [__] yeah but I don't TR I don't
trust you I don't trust you I have trust
issues and interest issues um gosh uh
you know when you auditioned and we can
keep all this when you auditioned for
that fabulous director did you did you
meet in person or was it um on the uh I
have a great audition story from it so I
had I had done two self tapes for it and
then they said okay come on and and in
and and do it for him for Chris Nolan
face to
face and
um I had met
Chris a
good 16 years prior he was scouting for
like the Dark Knight maybe or yeah I'm
not sure or or yeah maybe the Dark
Knight
and he was scouting at
uh Hollywood uh Los Angeles center
studios which is where we shot numbers
and we were the only show it was us and
madmen so it's this huge lot
downtown in the middle of downtown that
no one really uses much except for like
music videos come in for like two days
or you know some commercial some big
commercial like LeBron James will come
in for two days they need a Sound Stage
so they go for it there's all these
sound stages and um and madmen would be
there for like three months but we were
there for like 10 months out of the year
and all these movies would shoot there
for a day you know they shoot they
literally you've seen it in half the
movies you've seen this sort of building
that they use that that's there that
used to be the old like 76 Union SoCal
Gas building anyway he was there and uh
and I was like oh [__] there's Chris
Nolan and he came up to me and he said
hey I think you're great on that show
this was numbers and I was like
whoa crazy and then you think you know
the thing is your worst mind goes to oh
well he's there you know that person
forgot about me or that person enjoyed
that thing that I was in but has no
interest in ever working with me but
that was very nice to hear that and so
knowing I was going in for him face to
face was not so intimidating I was like
oh I know that this guy enjoyed my work
at one point and so that wasn't
intimidating what was intimidating was I
showed up and they were like you're the
only one here for this oh which is like
oh it's yours to lose thing and I'm sure
you've been in that I'd rather go
against people than be alone me too and
and I thought I was showing up and you
know I also like need the motivation
like I walk in and there's another actor
there I'm like I I got it's like all of
a sudden I this is not when I work with
people but when I audition against
people I'm like oh I got to I'm in a
championship fight and I got to knock
this guy out yep what can I like I know
what I feel like I know what he's going
to do so I got to do something different
so going in alone was a little scary um
because then you go holy moly like they
really I'm this is it's it's m to
lose this show is sponsored by better
help Ryan you ever feel like your brain
is getting in the way of living your
best life all the time yeah I would say
so like you know what you should do
what's good for you but you you just
can't seem to do it oh yeah yeah therapy
helps you figure out what's holding you
back so your brain can work for you
instead of against you and this is what
happens with um therapy you're you have
all these things bottled up and you need
to let them out and you need to talk to
a professional it really really helps
therapy is a great way to learn positive
coping skills and how to set boundaries
it empowers you to be the best version
of yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute it's so easy even I can do
it then you get matched with a licensed
therapist switch therapists anytime for
no additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like I
want to try someone else it's easy just
like that better help is truly the best
way to make your brain your friend give
it a try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com slash inside inside of you is
brought to you by discover if you like
using debit over credit don't you think
it's time you also get rewarded well now
you can with Discover cash back debit
it's a checking account that rewards
everyone with cash back on everyday
purchases plus there are no fees period
we're talking date nights thrifting the
latest trends nights out with your
friends and it's now earning you cash
back with discover cashback debit check
out eligibility and terms at
discover.com
slashback deit Discover Bank member
FDIC and I went in and he gave me I had
two scenes I hadn't there was no script
available and I assumed that those two
scenes were the whole part you know cuz
you don't assume you've been given
anything more than that anyway so I did
the two scenes and he had me do it three
times and I try to switch it up a little
each time and after the third time he
said I want you to do it again but this
time I want you to do it like you're
driving home from this audition and
thinking I should have done it that
way
wow wow and luckily and I came to know
Chris is a very sarcastic and very funny
person right and but in the moment I
don't know that and luckily I played it
off you know I I actually laughed I
didn't get nervous I kind of went that's
funny and then I thought and then I even
said
like my the my drive home I'm GNA do it
in the elevator um did the thing left
and was convinced I had ruined it like
totally convinced I'd ruined it and
you're driving home on your way back
from the other
I supposed to drive home I was actually
I was in LA and I was supposed to drive
back to my hotel I drove straight to a
brewery and just downed a bunch of beer
just by myself in at on like a Tuesday
on at 2 o'clock it's just literally me
at the brewery just getting just
drowning my sorrows and going holy [__]
I had one of the biggest opportunities
I've ever had and I blew it and um I was
about like three or four beers in pretty
rocked uh and the plan was to just you
know then sober up and drive home and
just spend the whole day at the
brewery and uh my agent called and said
you got
it the same day and I was plastered in
the parking lot of this Brewery I was
like needless to say I'm now 14 months
clean and sober I don't do that anymore
nice
yeah why not
good thanks man but uh but yeah like uh
wa wait so you you didn't know you
thought you had a couple scenes in this
movie and what's funny is I see you in
the movie and I'm like oh cool he's in
this he's got something and you're the
integral part of the movie so then I
went and read the script the next day I
got called in and then he they said
we're going to let you read the
script uh in the office and then we're
going to take it back for from you I was
like okay and the script was printed on
dark red paper so you can't copy it or
read
it hard to read it was that secretive
and I'm reading it I'm like well [__]
man there I am again and whoa [__] and
it came it dawned on me like he Chris
really believed in me you know you as an
actor you spend so much time going you
know I don't know who believes in me and
if they do I wish they would just show
up right now you know I know and then it
happens and that um it made me super
emotional you know he showed up after I
read it he wanted to talk to me about it
and I was just I had a [__] eating grin
on my face you know I was just like and
I just kept saying thank you I just kept
saying like thank thank you thank you
wow thanks and the coolest thing is like
as they were promoting the movie these
last few months I had a little secret
which which was that I wasn't just in it
I was in it a good deal you know and
then it was about like do I suck in it
like I hope I don't suck sucking did he
is he some somebody who after take would
go hey Dave that was great that was
great no no so it's cut or let's do
another one try it like this be a little
bit more remember that I told you that
great do that okay great all right good
let's move on yeah so he he works super
fast he shoots One camera at a time
nothing more than one camera
he doesn't have a video Village he has a
small hand Monitor and he was watching
my close-ups on like a hand Monitor and
he wasn't happy with like stuff the
first uh scene we did my stuff was
basically shot chronologically and the
first scene we did is the scene on the
train is pretty intimate scene with me
and Killian
Murphy and uh and Chris was like uh he
made me do 14 takes to my closeup and
this is a guy that does like three takes
typically and this is your first scene
you're shooting day now were you
thinking about oh my God everybody's
looking at me Killian Murphy thinks I'm
terrible I'm bombing I'm gonna get fired
yes all these things you're thinking of
you're obsessing oh consciously in the
moment and it doesn't help that Chris is
like I don't know what you're
doing and I'm I'm thinking to myself
well because I'm on that tiny monitor
you know but he wanted something
different than what I was planning and
you know I had to adjust on the fly but
you don't argue with Chris Nolan out of
respect because he doesn't he doesn't
he's one of those directors he doesn't
demand respect He commands respect he is
the hardest working man on the set he's
involved in everything there is no you
know assistant doing half his job for
him he isn't taking a break he never
sits down he never goes to the bathroom
jeez so o he's on OIC what's that he's
on
OIC that's right that's what he's on I
was like I love this genius guy and like
all I want to do is make him happy so we
did 14
takes and the next scene we did um we
did nine takes of my closeup and at the
end of it he came up to me and he said
well nine takes it's better than 14
which is what you did the first
time so but he's being
sarcastic oh yeah but he's the opposite
of like and there was one day where we
did a scene and I went up to him and I
said was that good and he said he
fishing for
compliments he really doesn't like that
really so let me ask you this because
I've done this before where I'm on set
and he the director wants something and
he's giving me now notes and I don't
even understand the notes it's like I'm
just going to do another take but I
don't even really get what he's saying
and I feel like if I keep asking him I
don't understand it's going to make it
worse I'll just do it and see if I get
lucky with my abilities right did you
feel like after eight nine 10 you're
just like oh I'm just trying something
different did you ever look at kilan
Murphy and go well here we go yeah no
because Chris you know Chris has so much
brevity in the way he gives notes he's
so specific and so smart about how to
get what he wants out of you I
just I guess I was just in a place of
stuck in what I had been doing for
months in the auditioning process and
and then you know what I had
planned and um it also like the literal
space that we were in that train car was
Tiny IMAX cameras are massive they're
like three times the size and it was him
his DP po POA uh Killian literally like
off camera sandwiched up against the
wall and so there's not a lot of
like mental space physical space
claustrophobic yeah and so I think what
I ended up happening was I was very much
here and I needed to be very much here
and it took me 14 takes to get there ah
it probably took me 10 and he gave me
four good ones do you go how many did
kly Murphy get how many takes on that
yeah less less a lot less did you go
home afterwards and call your wife and
say I I don't know I don't I this could
be my my first and last
day yes you did you were that nervous
you're gonna get fired 100% 100% yeah
you know that movie specifically because
you look at that cast and you go man
there's some heavy [__] hitters in
his cast yeah you know Downey and Oldman
and and and and kilan and the list goes
on it and Emily Blunt and Florence Pew
and you just go man I I can't suck in
this you know if I had a smaller role I
could kind of suck if I wanted to let
him suck in that scene I have to like
[__] chew this thing up and spit it
out I have to make something of this and
yeah I was really nervous I but everyone
was everyone in that movie was kind of
like wow was it's it's a murderer's row
it's one of the best casts ever and you
know one best ensembles and it was just
a murderer row you know I remember um
Jason Clark came in to do his scenes and
I did my one scene with him and even he
was like a little like and he had a lot
of dialogue too a lot of dialogue and he
has heavy moments and you could see that
he was up to the challenge and that he
was going to nail it but it came from a
place of I better nail it there wasn't
it wasn't the most laidback environment
yeah you got to step up it's like I I
know my lines inside out reverse forward
I I don't care if it's two lines I'm
going to know it a million percent plus
you're shooting on IMAX film so it's not
like digital where you can do this all
day like they're running out of money as
you [__] up every time you [__] up it's
a big deal yeah and so you know it was
just uh did they pay you well did you
get paid
well um yeah all right yeah what it was
it was surprising actually it wasn't bad
um good yeah yeah let me ask you this
when you do a show like numbers I I I
remember watching
numbers and I remember
thinking I could never do this I could
never play this part I could never I the
words he's saying the amount of dialogue
he has you're doing how many episodes a
year
22 yeah how much dialogue did you have
per episode on
average uh a lot but you know
um I I I I it was it was it was the job
you know that was job it was the job I
mean but like listen to me are you are
you a you have photographic uh memory no
you
don't I maybe on some level I do how how
long does it take you to learn your
lines so for numbers what happened was
we started doing the show and uh you
know I'd go home I'd learn the night
before wake up the next morning and it
was such complicated jargon what I was
speaking that I'd forget it so I'd be in
the shower going holy crap I stayed up
for three hours straight working on
these lines and I can't remember them
and there were days on set where I had
like many crises you know in the
beginning and two things had to happen
one I had to stop being afraid of not
knowing the lines
my fear of not getting them you you know
this with with heavy with heavy dialogue
the more afraid you are of not knowing
it the less chance you're going to have
to know it like you you've got to not be
afraid and I was really afraid so I had
to drop that how do you drop that how do
you just drop
that
[Music]
um I I came up with a plan but it it
wasn't a plan that everybody liked I
will say that I will say that what was
the plan
okay so I was like I went to the
producers and I said the the the genius
of the character is catching up with the
capabilities of the
actor and I was like and I don't want
you guys to like rewrite anything
because I'm stupid you know I don't want
you to have to do that um one of the
things I asked them to do was they would
like give me like a whole long speech
and in the speech I'd have the same
complicated words eight times within
that speech so let's say the word is
algorithm okay I'd have to say algorithm
eight times within that speech and the
problem the way the my brain works at
least is like I get to the third
algorithm and think it was the sixth you
know what I mean and skip over a bunch
of dialogue as a result I'd [__] up
right so I asked them I said if there's
any way to not do that to like if you
know to reword it get your get your
thesaurus out and like what's another
word for algorithm like call it a
formula call it whatever you know and
they did that was really that was the
only ask I had for them that's not big
of an ask no I would have said Q cards
earwig that's all I asked well so then
what I did I said and here's the deal
I'm going to come in not knowing him and
they were like what and I was like I'm
GNA come in not knowing my lines and
they were not happy with that and I said
here's what's going to happen I'm going
to come in I'm going to not know them at
all I'm then going to spend the 20
minutes that it takes for you to set up
the first shot after
rehearsal with our script
supervisor and if she can't do it we got
to get somebody who can anyone who's
willing to on set will do it with me and
I'm going to cram them I'm just going to
cram the [__] out of them pressure's on
I got 150 people waiting on me to learn
these lines that's how I'm going to
learn these lines [__] and and so that's
how we did it for six years and um and
you know first takes sucked you know it
cost a couple takes you know I would
[__] up but then by the third take I get
it and what was great about it was
you're watching me kind of get it as I'm
getting as I'm performing and it looks
like to the audience the audience sees a
mathematician coming up with the ideas
as he's saying it as think lines
remembering his lines so it looks
spontaneous and so it started to work
and I started to make sure that I you
know first takes were better second
takes I we did we moved so fast in that
show we ended up doing 10hour days most
of the time um nine pages in 10 hours
like we rock rock that show and so
it got easier for me got easier for
everybody and then no one cared
everybody was like fine this is the way
we're doing it this is the way could you
do it now if Christopher Nolan said I
just wrote a paragraph for you can you
do it no way see on numbers
unfortunately or fortunately numbers
became you do 22 Episodes a year it
becomes monotonous it becomes a job um
I'm not saying that there you don't keep
the work honest or that there isn't
passion behind it but at a certain point
you just go wow I got to get the job
done so I may not
be um cons as concerned with how I
perform this scene as I am with getting
the lines right right on movie with
Chris Nolan with when any other thing
like I have to know the lines before I
show up to set like I must know them
backwards and forwards and what I do is
I learn them and then um my I go into
the shower and I recite them backwards
and that's kind of not word by word but
sentence by sentence I go from the
sentence all the way to the first and if
I can do that it's just confidence just
knowing like oh okay I did them
literally backwards and forwards and so
now I know them so you know them even
when you think you I pretty much know
them you want to go a million percent
more of knowing that yeah because I
don't want to be hindered by the lines I
want to be able to perform you know what
I mean like and the better I know them
the more sort of Loosey Goosey I can be
with my performance just do weird stuff
and crazy but when you know him that way
well is there ever a point where they go
oh you know add this little thing in
there does that [__] you yeah no I've
been I got good at that because I've
done a lot of multicam sitcoms a lot of
failed multic cams I've done eight
failed multicam sitcoms and when I say
failed I mean they went to series and
never made it like got cancelled before
13 episodes I've done couple of those
yeah yeah yeah and you know they come at
you with rewrites you know while you're
shooting you
know whatever
new jokes or whatever and so yeah you
got to learn that stuff on the flight so
I got good at that I got good at that
thankfully you uh talked briefly you
skimmed over it you said you know you
got thyroid cancer and yet you know the
year before something you had a mental
breakdown you're like oh that's why the
thyroid but when you say mental
breakdown what happens when you have a
mental break because I because I I feel
like I've had one as well and I had to
go and get
myself you know I I just went through a
really tough time and a lot of people
out there do a lot of people every I
feel like every great actor should have
one
um um because it really changed
everything uh I got married so basically
what happened was my show ended numbers
ended I didn't know who I was anymore I
didn't know what my career was I got
married and the very next day I flipped
the [__] I flipped out we made the
mistake I made the mistake we booked uh
our honeymoon the next morning in St
Barts beautiful place except we went
during the off seon so everything was
closed and when we got there uh the the
island had just had like a massive storm
so the internet and TV was knocked out
so here I come from like the most wild
rockus night of my life and this huge
momentous occasion and I find myself in
an island in the middle of nowhere where
all the stores are closed all the
restaurants are closed the only food I
can get is at the hotel there's no one
at the hotel [__] place is empty and
I got like Island fever and that's how
the nervous breakdown sort of started so
my so three three and a half days in I
said to my wife I said we got to get out
of here and we had booked an 8-day
honeymoon and we left we left my much to
her parents chrin you know my in-laws
were like what the [__] is going on I
was like I'm I'm freaking out I'm
freaking out I can't stop panicking I
can't I have bad anxiety I cannot stop
panicking the anxiety then turned into
really deep paralyzing
depression I I became agoraphobic I
couldn't leave the house and it went on
for nine months it was a full nine
months right after you get married
and right after my show ends which was a
big successful show yeah so my my wife
God bless her was just like who is this
person and you tricked me you basically
you tricked me we're married now and
you're a mess how did this happen and I
felt terrible I felt so bad you know and
it made things worse you know that I had
to face her and I was scared of her I
was like scared of her coming coming
home cuz I didn't want to be a burden on
her um it was really really intense
really intense time um and I got sober
during it I got you know I tried
everything I could you know I wasn't
into getting on meds but then I sort of
sort of you know you know just put I
just realized I was powerless over what
was happening and again it was all
happening mostly because my thyroid
wasn't working but I didn't know that um
but yeah I I became a total reck loose
shut in nervous mess ball of depression
like scary depression deep deep deep
depression for nine months did she did
you think she was gonna leave
you
no uh no really what made you feel that
way that she wasn't going to leave me
yeah um
she's the most wonderful person on Earth
and I
knew and and she was my motivation to
get better you know if I was alone or
whatever single dude I would have Pro
maybe even offed myself to be honest
with you you were that bad oh it was bad
it was really really bad I lost my mind
you know you lose your mind you know you
you just you lose it and uh you know and
Friends also my friends stepping up up
and sort of going like oh he's not like
you know I'm a kind of a jokey guy and
it's like oh he's not telling jokes
anymore like he's like you know this is
not the guy we knew he really is he
really is
uninteresting yeah finally I really was
finally is that interesting well they
couldn't be around I start I'd be crying
all the time you know it was that bad
you know had a serious chemical
imbalance so you know um yeah it was a
tough time tough time I'm glad it's
behind me but I learned so much from it
you know it was the ultimate fall you
know it was a huge fall and two years
later I took her on a proper honeymoon
you know it was two years later we went
we went to Ireland and Scotland and we
drank our asses off and had a blast
that's great we went for weeks and it
was awesome how about that yeah things
work out I I think that you
know I've been there I've been to the
darkest of darks and
uh you know it's funny because you you
you do people have this sort
of idea that it's a you know when you
people who kill themselves how could
they be so selfish how could they be
this how when you get so low to a point
it's like nothing else matter the only
thing that matters is just not being
there it's like I can't be in my own
[__] body I can't be it's like this
Darkness I can't even imagine that next
step of Darkness that you know Robin
Williams or some you know people must
have felt that you know so I never look
at it as like that I look at as like no
they were very sick they were very we
have no idea where they went it's not
fair to say that and so you can you you
could understand that but what what got
you out of it what got you out of that I
mean I know you said the thyroid thing
made you go oh that's what it was but
did it sort of go away before the
thyroid thing no um it was getting
better I went to a lot of therapy man um
I mean I found myself literally in fetal
positions on the floor of therapists
offices but they didn't give up on me no
one gave up on me um I reached out to a
crisis manager um because I was in
crisis man I went to what did I what I
went to some weird [__] like super
weird la hypnotist thing you know brain
scan thing like I did everything I
possibly could um and yeah meds helped
meds helped big time you know thank God
you know like I'm a big proponent of do
what you need to do you know you don't
have to suffer you know life if if
you're in a situation where you're
suffering and you don't have
to uh you got to take every route you
can to to alleviate suffering no one
deserves to suff suffer especially for
prolonged periods of time you know
there's some suffering that can't be
helped but this this is suffering that
can be helped and I was suffering I
really was man and uh but you know just
a good support system and um and uh and
just you know not giving up just sort of
not you know I there was part of me that
was just like I can't go out like this
like I'm not going out like this but I
turned down jobs you know I couldn't
work I didn't want to travel I was
afraid to go any where I was afraid of
going to you know Wood Ranch at the
Grove you know like I couldn't go to a
barbecue my favorite barbecue restaurant
you know like it was that and you were
afraid you gonna have a panic attack or
you're gonna pass out I was having I
literally dude it was like a nine Monon
panic attack it was kind of the craziest
thing ever I I I you know I had the
worst panic attack at my 50th
birthday all my friends were meeting me
at a restaurant and when we had this
back room and my friend Tom walked up up
and I go I'm having a panic attack right
now I can't I got to go home I can't do
this and he's like dude dude calm down
you it's your birthday your it's your
friends it's okay and I stuck it out
like I but I sat in a corner of the
restaurant where all my friends were
talking were you there Ryan no uh Ryan's
here you don't you don't know Ryan's
here anyway um I
was I just I I felt like I'm going to
pass out out uh I I it was just so awful
and I just wanted to go to my bed you
know I'd wake up and I would just like
30 minutes in I want to go back to bed I
just wanted the day to go away it was
[__] disastrous and I'm I'm glad you
know thank God people were patient with
me and I was just uh finally the right
meds sort of worked for me and it it did
change my life in a way you know it's
definitely changed me in a lot of ways
because I think I I've had this panic
panic uh or this uh anxiety since I was
a child I didn't even know it I thought
it was just part of me and it was all
the dysfunction and all this craziness
that was going around that it was just
part of me and I'm like why am I so why
am I so nervous about this why am I so
nervous about this why and I realized
wow I thought it was just situational
like oh I'm having anxiety midlife but I
think
it it stemmed from years and years of
letting this go on and finally my body
said stop it we're not doing this
anymore and it broke down it just broke
down mentally and physically so um so
you started to get
better but I mean just to to your to
what you're saying I'm glad you're
feeling better I mean the thing is is
like people really
don't panic uh is exponential right you
panic and then you panic that you're
panicking Y and then you P that you
panicked that you're panicked and it
goes on and on and it builds to a point
of of complete Madness you know um so
yeah it's important to like just have
people who understand near you you
know you know like luckily since I've
been in the situation where I've know
people who where I've been able to help
people through those moments of of their
own you know so yeah did you have do you
have any celebrity friends that reached
out and tried to help
you it uh I'm asking that because you
know it's like you know celebrity
friends but are they really
friends yeah no no they were they were I
had a couple celebrity friends that were
worried about me but didn't do anything
no right they didn't I was beyond help
though man I was beyond help I I really
I was I I had to do it mostly on my own
in a therapist office with a trained
professional you know there was no there
was support you could give me support
and say hey I'm worried about you and
anything you need but there was nothing
I could I
couldn't it was just too much and it's
gone now you don't get anxiety anymore I
get you know every once in a while I get
a little tinge of something um you know
but yeah not really man it's gone it's
it's it's gone but you know uh cognitive
behavioral therapy taught me to like not
be afraid of it and to actually welcome
it you know if I have a panic attack now
I go okay I hear you how bad can you get
you know let's bring it on you know that
way I put an leash on a gnarly dog you
know what I mean and whether I like it
or not that that dog is mine I got to
raise that dog and fix that dog somehow
you know stop it from being so gnarly if
I let go of the leash it's going to go
attack somebody you know so like I gotta
hold on to that leash for dear life and
um
and and it's mine instead of being
afraid of the dog just owning it you
know like I own my panic I own it it
makes it so that when I do have a panic
attack I can just sort of go oh okay
this is happening instead of freaking
out did you find um through all this and
then you know the thyroid and you
realize oh this is what caused it and
you're like oh good this is what caused
it all that stuff that nine months was
just because of this but along the way
with therapy and cognitive behavior and
I don't know if you did EMDR but
whatever you did did you learn a lot
about things that maybe have happened in
your childhood or things that happened
along the way that Al just helped clear
your head more that it was worth all
that absolutely I mean
um you know I I had to face a lot of
stuff you know I I there was stuff that
I had used as
motivation for many years there was
stuff that I had used to make me angry
and I thought it was okay to be an angry
person um and live angry and be bitter
and you know um there was stuff that I
had to sort of come to a real acceptance
of a real peace with uh or else I wasn't
going to get out of that that situation
wow and you know
forgiveness for not only other people
but for myself you know and uh and uh
you know um sort of chipping away at the
self- involvement you know like chipping
away at the ego which had become massive
on at on some level in a way that I was
I was I was a nice guy I could be your
friend but man I I
was I was me me me 247 and part of
getting married freaked me out because
of that it was like oh I I I I'm I'm
obligated to something someone now you
know it really and I wasn't my ego was
too big to handle it you know and uh and
I needed a chip away I really needed to
chip away you know I'm one of those
people that like I think I I'm I'm a
messiah with an inferiority complex you
know like you know like it's it's it's
it's it's all or nothing and I have to
find a middle ground and then having
kids has really helped you know like you
know kids will tell you the truth about
yourself yeah which is that you're ugly
fat untalented not that
impressive uh and it's the best it's the
best medicine man it is well I'm glad
you went through all that and you know
um it's it's uh it's tough It's it's
tough fac it's tough admitting to
yourself that you have a problem or you
have this you know cuz I I I could
certainly sit here and say yeah I've got
an ego yeah I could be completely
selfish yeah but uh I'm aware of it and
I also could be very giving and
thoughtful and all these things and and
those bad parts of me they kind of
linger around they're always going to be
there and um as long as I'm aware of
them and as long as I don't let them get
out of hand or make them change me or or
you know or you know
it's it's for so long I punished myself
really like you know you're [__] ugly
you're [__] [__] you're [__]
this and I would just you know and now I
try to just go hey you're all right man
you're all right you're all right kid
you're all right kid hey we got some
this is so awesome man this is like you
don't understand how this helps so many
people and the listeners and they're so
loyal and you know this is this is the
stuff that people want to hear I I
believe you know you were you were
talking about um you know when
Christopher Nolan came up to you many
moons ago when you did numbers and goes
hey you're really good in that and um
you also said that you know most of the
time it's just like hey someone likeed
my work and nothing will ever happen
with that right most likely most of the
time and that's happened so many times
with me where you know I remember
quitting Tarantino was like [__] Lex
Luther I [__] love you man I go
you're quitting Tarantino I [__] love
you are you kidding me and I go I gotta
we got to work together goes oh yeah man
for sure for sure man and nothing you
know I've had other directors big you
know come up to me and nothing nothing
it's always nothing it almost never
happens right you know and that's
like I don't know I just wanted to say
that does that happen a lot to you look
you know it's rare when it happens and
then I never expect it to happen again
like it's it because it's it's super
rare I I went to dinner one night at a
restaurant and Stephen Soderberg was
sitting with a couple friends at the
table over never met him in my life
and he got up left and I'm with my wife
we're eating and the waiter comes over
and goes Stephen soda Brook paid for
your meal I said what someone had pay I
was like what and [__] there was a
little note from Steven Soderberg saying
whatever and I was like what the [__]
and so I thought oh [__] man he wants to
work with me man or something you know I
should send him flowers or something so
we call his office the next day and he's
like we're like day he you know like I
was super that was so sweet can I send
flowers or something and they're like no
he does it for
everybody he does it all the time he
buys people din left oh God why'd she
say
that it makes you just feel like
[__] yeah what are you gonna do I
remember I had a Golden Globe or not a
Golden Globe [__] sorry it's way way
off a Saturn award and I was holding a
Saturn award and with Steven Spielberg
and he was like Hey congratulations
that's great and I go yeah thanks so
much you too you know and we took a
picture together and we talked for a
minute I was just praying that Stephen
would have been like you're really
terrific in that show and I I'd love to
work with you but that never happened
damn it damn it Stephen don't you watch
Smallville what's the matter with you um
this has been terrific you're so
engaging you're so open and I just think
this is yeah this I'm a mirror I'm a
mirror no you're you're a great guy
you're a great guy doing great who's
who's the uh who's hey who's your
favorite actor of all time in terms of
Quality
quality mine's Gary Oldman who is it
yeah I have a
tie it's a three-way
tie okay it's Kate
Blanchett it's
dairo and it's clous kinsky really yeah
those three those are that's my Holy
Trinity of acting I would say
Nicholson very very much up there for me
Gary
Oldman
also and uh the best actress of all time
Merill Street yeah Merill Street yeah I
mean yeah all very much up there
funniest would go to uh Kristen wig
probably one of the fun her and Danny
McBride are the two funniest people in
the plan it to me okay okay what do you
think all right I think they're very
funny I'm I'm an Eddie Murphy guy all
the way through Eddy Murphy and Martin
Short Martin Short Martin Short that's
good always have been like obsessed with
those two who's the one actor that
you've met who is one of your favorites
and they couldn't have
been better and
nicer oh wow um and you were like wow
thank God they were cool
uh wow that's a good
question um kind of I gota it's a tough
one but
uh I gotta say all the biggest actors
like the biggest names I've worked with
have been awesome you know Downey's
awesome Clooney's awesome Brad Pitt's
awesome uh yeah those those three it's
the smaller ones that aren't that great
right the ones that aren't as big maybe
you get a little attitude with that you
know the one it's not even the smaller
ones it's the ones it's the big ones
that have lasted a really long time and
then you're like oh I'm this is why they
lasted because they're
nice like they're not just talented but
they're super nice and they make it easy
for people to shoot movies with them and
then you go oh that's the key is just be
like super nice who is the worst you
can't say
it but you have one in your mind right
you have one in your mind the worst
famous person that I met as a fan as a
fan I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell you one thing okay um I'll tell you
a funny story really quick okay and then
and then I'll I'll try to make this
quick I'm 20 one or 22 years old 23
actually and I get my first lead part in
a small Indie movie tiny Indie movie
it's going to shoot in New York City and
the producer has us come to her
apartment in Tribeca for a table read
and I go to the table read and you know
we do the reading and the director is
like hey stick around after the table
read I want to talk to you specifically
about your role I said great I stick
around there's Pizza there and I'm 23
years old and at the end of our no
session he says hey you want to take the
pizza with you and I'm like hell yeah
and I walk out of her apartment and
directly across the
hall with their apart with his apartment
door open holding his apartment door
open is Robert [__] dairo right and I
freeze because I had one week prior just
seen Raging Bull and I I felt I froze I
was scared of him and he slammed the
door in my face and I I C would have an
it turn and standing by the elevator in
this building are two are his two twin
children he had two he had twins and
they're they're like four or five at
this point maybe six and they're
standing there and they see that I have
pizza and they want the pizza right and
I'm like no you can't have the pizza and
I'm also super afraid to go knock on
Dao's door and say hey you left your
kids out here I assume he knows the kids
are out there like I I gotta get out of
there man I just got my the door slammed
in my face I'm scared and like an idiot
I push the elevator button and the
elevator comes and these two get in the
elevator okay so now Robert Deniro's
four or five-year-old twins are in the
elevator of this building he's in his
apartment if I leave to go knock on his
door to tell him the elevator door
closes they go downstairs so I'm stuck
with his twins I go into the elevator
with them I say here's what's going to
happen they're like can we have the
pizza I'm like no I'm not going to touch
them I'm not going to force them
physically force them out so I'm like
here's what's going to happen we're
going to go down to the lobby I'm going
to press your floor and you go right
back up and you go home okay so we go
down the lobby I press their floor Lobby
door closes 22-year-old 23-year-old
stupid me is like okay I did it get out
of here go
home few years ago Tribeca Film Festival
I'm a juror they have this lunch in Aron
Rogers is
there and there's Robert dairo and I
think you know I'm gonna tell Robert
dairo this
story so I go up to Rob dairo and I say
hey Mr daero I'm so sorry to bother you
my name's Dave and
I'm just I just want to let you know I'm
a huge fan of yours and I just want to
tell you a funny story and I tell him
the story I just told you and he laughs
he laughs thank God he's not pissed he
laughs yeah his kids are okay they're
grown up nothing ever happened I go they
they they announce hey okay everybody
now we're all gonna go upstairs and uh
and deliberate on our
films I said great I go to the elevator
to go upstairs to this room where I'm
going to deliberate with Aaron Rogers
and whatever waiting for the elevator
and Robert dairo comes and stands next
to me waiting for the same elevator and
like an idiot I turn to him I go well
you'll be the third daero I ride an
elevator with and start laughing and he
goes I'm gonna take the stairs and he
did oh my God I'm gonna take the
stairs thenna take the stairs and boom
took the stairs and that was it 75y old
man took the
stairs you should have said I hope you
fall fall down
him you old
[__] yeah that's that's you know I mean
what a shame you think he would have
been like you're funny you're funny
that's good but no yeah I thought that's
what I was gonna get oh hey back oh God
gosh well I wish we went out on a on a
on a good note but that's a sad a sad no
it's great I love that story that's
[__] fantastic uh well don't always
meet your Heroes uh I love you buddy
this has been great I'll let you know
when it airs I I couldn't have had more
fun uh this is this is awesome this is
exactly what I was hoping for you too
brother man I'll see you soon all
right great guy you know someone who's
been around someone who's worked someone
who's been through up and
downs ups and downs MH um yeah I really
enjoyed this I really enjoyed him I just
he's such a likable person and innately
good good soul I could always see that I
could see through [__] the I've been
sitting here talking to 300 plus guests
and I got to tell you that I can see
through people pretty easily within the
first 20 minutes I kind of get it I'm
like I know I I know what's going on and
they you know you can hide things to a
point and I don't try to pry things out
of people I don't you know but just
having candid conver and most people are
genuinely good and have something to
share
and he was one of them so thank you um
if you missed the intro and you fast
forwarded make sure you roll
back uh okay why don't we get to the top
tier patrons if you don't know what a
patron is they're uh patrons of the
podcast they go to patreon.com inside of
you and you become a patron and one of
the perks is these people get their
names shouted out at the end of every
episode and I couldn't do it without
them so if I overemphasize one name it
doesn't mean they're just not as
important as any other name but they are
no I'm kidding uh let's do this these
are the top tier patrons I love
you Nancy D Leah and Kristen little Lisa
Yukiko Leah by the way uh I ate all
those stop you know I'm just gonna can I
just like give you money instead of
getting Girl Scout cookies because I
torture myself I eat so much and it's so
bad for me so next time just say hey you
know just invoice me and I'll just give
you the money I don't I don't feel like
I can't eat that stuff anymore it's so
good and I just want to bury myself in
it little Lisa thank you for the this
shirt I'm wearing right now Hockey Night
in Canada little Lisa got me that I love
it that's cool it's brand for you right
yeah I'm watching hockey right after
this when this is over so we got to it's
little Jason mask too yeah little Jason
mask that's sitting next to you uh
Yukiko love you Yukiko you have
supported this podcast for so so long
and you're so far away but you're right
here with me uh Jill e you've been
around you've been
around thank you for all the love and
Brian hin and Camp gosh I'm going to
thees mode thing Nico P Robert B Jason W
Sophie M Raj C Sophie I just saw you in
Rhode Island Joshua D Jennifer N Stacy L
Jamal F Janelle B just saw Janelle Mike
E
Elon Supremo 99 more Santiago M the
statue maker he's so supportive I love I
love that guy want to read some lean P
Chad W hi hi hi guys matd s Belinda n
Dave H Sheila wa Dave Dave H Dave who
Dave Hall it's only Dave Dave Hall I
love Dave Hall he's so relaxed he just
talks like this Dave H reminds me of
like a Gary Oldman Dave ho in it yeah go
ahead hey it's all right uh Sheila G
Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom n Talia M
Betsy D ran and C Corey K Dev Nexon
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Joey M
Eugene and
Leah all right that was good that was
one breath Eugene Leah yeah and Betsy D
i't I haven't heard from Betsy D in a
while and Ray hadada gotta have another
concert you guys got to come to the
concert sunspin is going to be playing
soon in December so I hope everybody
turns out and comes to the show we don't
do as many shows as we used to so please
support uh if you go to sunspin decom
you could you know you guys will know
when we're playing
Angela F Mel s Christine s Eric H Shane
R Andrew Andrew M
Andrew Amanda R Kevin e Stephanie K
Jerel jam and J Leanne
J I feel like I know these people I do
Luna R Mike F Stonehenge Brian L Jules M
Kendall L Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P
Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F Marian Louise
L Romeo the band Frank B Jen t
I'll just read the rest I I got lost
Nikki L April r hi guys how are you
ladies Randy s
jdw sounds like jdw and Associates oral
P remember Oral B that still exists yeah
and he's oral P oral or it could be oral
AAL Rachel D Melissa H Nick W Stephanie
and heaven and Charlene a couldn't do
the show without you guys I really
appreciate appreciate you and uh thank
you for being here I am Michael rosenbom
from the Hollywood Hills in California
I'm ran T I'm here too yes Little Wave
be good to yourself and you're good
enough just remember that right Ryan you
were good enough yes you
[Music]
too